[Music]
it's a project that has been going on
and off for a few years now and so I
like to tell you about the solution that
we have in production right now but also
about where we started and a bunch of
things that we've learned along the way
so the outline of my talk is as such I
mean first I just want to talk about
what the problem is then go over a
couple of the algorithms that we've used
to address the problem we've been
testing these out in experiments in
stores in production as usual after
you've run some experiments usually need
to go back and fix up your algorithms a
bit which is what happened to us and
finally I'll just go over the
infrastructure and architecture we're
using for our application so um
people still actually buy physical
newspapers yes you should too
we have about 47,000 sales outlets in
the country and some more abroad so this
is still a big part of the business this
is an important problem that The Times
has to address so the question really is
how many newspapers should we deliver to
every store every day and so clearly if
you get this wrong you're wasting money
if you send way too many then you spent
all this money printing them up and
distributing them and it's a waste
because we have to eat that cost of the
extra sales or the extra papers and if
we don't send enough then Congress Lee
we're not meeting demand and so we're
missing out on possible sales and the
way this works in the business is
something I didn't realize until I
started working at the Times a couple of
years ago that if you're a coffee shop
or something and you want to sell the
newspaper you just call up the times
when you say sign me up
and then the times has to decide how
many newspapers you're gonna get you
don't have any say and how many you're
getting and so this is really up to us
to determine this properly and if we
don't do it right then then we take the
financial hit so this uh these
individual sales coffees are what we
called a single copy problem so the
process for this is really a weekly
batch process it's a like every week
depending on what distributor it is at
one point each week we get a dump of all
the sales information for recent sales
and typically the info is delayed by one
or two weeks just because it takes a
while it's a very manual process to get
the data in of how many newspapers are
actually sold in each spot so um there
is this delay of you know something
between 10 days and a few weeks of the
sales information but once a week this
data comes in we just pick it up via FTP
ingest it into our systems
then we retrain our models to determine
the demand and how many to send once we
figured this out we just upload our
output back to the FTP site which is
just then our handoff to the print
circulation group the turnaround time on
this process for us is usually about a
few hours it depends on the distributor
which I'm working with but so it's not
super real-time or anything but it it
isn't you know it has to get done this
needs to this to be a robust process
since this is a problem that's been
around for as long as the newspaper has
been around we're clearly replacing or
augmenting or replacing an existing
algorithm and the existing algorithm is
made up of a bunch of heuristics a lot
of if-then statements basically the idea
behind the existing algorithm is that
you take the highest sales from the past
few weeks of data for each store and
also for each day of the week because
sales patterns vary a lot by eight days
of the week particularly Sundays which
papers way bigger costs more it's just
sort of different product
so you take the highest hill over the
recent weeks you multiply it by some
factor a which is something a little bit
more than one you add an extra factor P
which is maybe something around you know
one or a few and that's how many you're
gonna deliver for the next day I can be
here are really hand-tuned it depends on
the type of store it is depends on where
it is depends I don't even know it
depends on and I spent a while trying to
figure out what this depends on but the
code for this is interspersed among
about 4600 lines of COBOL um so that was
fun and here's some of it and so you can
see I mean this is like part of it and
this is what's contained on the screen
it's really difficult to go through and
particularly also difficult to modify
not just because it's COBOL but because
it's not modular at all this this code
doesn't just do this it does a whole
bunch of other stuff but like sprinkled
through here are key things that you
need to notice that are not at all
obvious so that's one of the reasons why
we started working with the circulation
group to do this project because the
existing algorithm is really hard to
modify and optimize given extra data
that they could be using and also this
is a really quintessential time series
modeling problem and it's it's perfect
for for data science algorithms don't
algorithms the algorithms for this can
really be broken up into two parts the
first question that we're trying to
answer is how many newspapers do we
think will be bought you know what
what's the demand for a newspaper every
day in a store once we know that the
next part of the question is how many
should we actually deliver because if we
think that you know five papers are
gonna sell down the street on Thursday
then if we knew it was exactly five we
just sent five but clearly there's noise
associated with this and we want to send
some extras because it costs much less
for us to print up a couple papers and
send them then the money we'd make by
having an extra sale
so the question of exactly how many
extras we should send is this policy
function and also here I wrote draw
because the kind of term that they use
for the number of papers you send is the
draw so I'll probably say that a lot
so the first algorithm that was
implemented was just a standard auto
regression algorithm like one so and
Dale kam is the one who brought this up
but I wanted to make a point of write
names in my slides because in this
project it has been going on for longer
than I've been working at the times and
a lot of people have contributed like
the main pieces of this work and those
people are not necessarily me so this is
one case and also Nick I know Nick's
worked a lot on this too so the the auto
regression like one was our first
algorithm that we tested out by Dale who
really was the first one to work on this
project so the idea is really that the
sale that we're concerned with you know
today for example is a linear function
of the last week sales and it has
coefficients Phi and then an additive
constant C and some noise epsilon for
this and for all our models actually
we're fitting one model per store per
day of the week and for this we're using
the past year's worth of data to fit for
the model parameter C and Phi so the
model hyper parameter is like how long
of a data time span we used to train the
model and you know a are like one versus
like and these are things that were
optimized at the time of developing the
model are you saying cross-validation
and so we use this to determine the
demand or our newspapers then how many
should we send is the policy function
and for this implementation we just use
the ceiling of the demand to make sure
that we're always sending at least as
many as we think will sell and usually a
bit more also there's this factor of the
bump in
and that if we've been selling out we
want to send just an extra one because
the problem is that if there's a sellout
you don't really know what the demand
was all you know is that it was at least
as many as you sold and so this is one
way of addressing that problem so that
you're automatically even though your
model is not really going to understand
that that the demand was higher this
will just manually increase the the draw
in the future so that your future
training data will be more likely to be
complete this was implemented in python
using stats models for the auto
regression algorithm we also had a flask
app hosting some plots that were updated
weekly to monitor how the drawers and
the sales were going how the profit was
going it's a weekly back to job so it
was runs by cron on a local server but
we didn't use like separate dev and
fraud environments we didn't really have
any nice deployment practices we just
sort of SCP top the code up to the
server so you know it worked but there
was some improvement to be made in the
data engineering sense but first I want
to talk about an improvement that we
made in the algorithm since this one was
written by Doreen Goldman and so the
Poisson regression is the next major
model that we build and the it has a lot
of similarities actually to the auto
regression but so this some similarities
are that again the today's sale is a
linear function of previous sales in
this case it's not just last week it's
also the last year to get some input
about seasonality and we're using again
about a year's worth of data to train
the model but it's a force on regression
meaning that we're assuming that the
sales distribution is drawn from a
Poisson distribution rather than
Gaussian and so the plot is just to show
the difference in the shape of these
distributions for the case of expected
sales equals one and you can just see
that the Poisson is in blue the gas cans
in green even if you have the same
expected sales the noise distribution is
different such that in the Poisson case
you the chances of getting like a lot
more sales is significantly higher and
so you want to take this into account
when you are optimizing how many to send
given that you're gonna have some noise
now well the other reason obviously to
use Poisson distribution is because our
sales are integer newspapers and often
they're small numbers and so this is
great just the inappropriate
distribution to use the other main
improvement in this model as opposed to
the previous one is that we're
considering sellouts as part of the
likelihood function when we're doing the
optimization so to go over what goes
into the likelihood function this is
what I just said before this is it's the
definition of the Poisson distribution
here Z is the demand for our newspapers
I had a given store and lambda is the
parameter that's parameterizing our
Poisson distribution here so Z is a
Poisson distributed latent variable
demand now lambda is really what we want
to figure out is the expected demand
so we're parameterizing it by some
weights theta and features X and our
features X are the previous sales in
that store and this is where the machine
learning comes in to optimize to fit
these parameters data
so in terms of the probability of of
what probability of our data this is the
probability of B being the number of
papers bought given D the number we
delivered and lambda the expected sales
they print the poisson parameter and
then this equals the term on the right
hand side just by putting in the actual
demands E and then marginalizing over it
but this now is separable so as it into
two components we have the probability
of the numbers paper of number of papers
bought given the demand and how many we
delivered times the probability of the
demand given lambda so this is what is
the Poisson distribution and this is
really just two terms depending on the
case of sellouts or not so this is the
probability of number but given demand
and draw so if we delivered more than
the demand then the the number bought is
just gonna be the same as the demand but
it if there's a sell out then what we
know is that the number bought is gonna
be the same as the number we delivered
and so then this probability splits into
these two terms depending on whether or
not the demand was less than or equal to
or greater than the the number of papers
we delivered and so then this is the
probability that we can use in or the
maximum likelihood estimation to
optimize to find lambda and as a
parameter as a function of our features
Thanks so now that we have determined
what we believe the demand is how many
newspapers should we deliver and this is
actually a solves problem um if this is
an analytical solution there's no
machine learning in this part at all
it's called it's known as the news
vendor algorithm and we're basically
just optimizing for profit profit is the
price of the newspaper times however
many we've sold which in this case is
the min
of however many we've delivered or the
demand - the cost that it costs us to
print it up and deliver it times how how
many we sent so that's very intuitive so
if you take the derivative of this and
say zero you find that in the case where
you're maximizing for profit it's true
that the probability that the demand is
less than or equal to the number you
deliver it is equal to price minus cost
over price it's very simple so in so
what we're trying to do now is determine
what the best D is so we can just take
the optimal draw D to be the one that
satisfies this condition and the
probability distribution here is the
cumulative distribution function of the
Poisson distribution since the sales are
person and we gives brute force scan
through how whatever values of the
possible number of papers to deliver to
find the lowest one that satisfies this
and then that's our optimal one do we
want to send okay so that is the
description of the algorithm that is our
actual main algorithm at this point when
we were going about implementing this
this was really the time to refactor our
code because we were going from one
algorithm to a second one and we knew
that we would want to test others in the
future and so we wanted to just modular
as our code and we changed the
algorithms to be in a class structure
with a scikit-learn type of interface so
that it would be very plug-and-play and
we could easily test out new ones so it
has the typical things like transform
fit and predict but also a policy
function since that's the main output of
the algorithms also of course it was a
good time to put together some common
library functions that all the
algorithms would want to use
so now that we have our algorithms we
want to test them in particular compared
to the existing BAU like business as
usual algorithm and the first thing we
needed to do to test them was to match
up some treatment and control stores so
that we could make some nice apples to
apples comparisons and to do this I mean
the approach we took is really simple
but needs to be done we're just really
matching stores by their sales there are
typical sales on the dates of the week
so to get a treatment group of stores in
which to test one of our algorithms we
just took a random sample from all of
the stores we want to make sure that our
random sample approximates the total
sales distribution just so that we have
a representative group and then for each
member of the treatment sample just take
out of the remainder of the stores the
store with the closest sales
distribution to our treatment store so
that works just fine as long as you kind
of trial and error find these cases that
you're screwing up and put in some
clauses to make your process safer for
example you know if you're matching on
me and sales you also want to make sure
that the variance is you know roughly
comparable and you don't have like some
crazy disparate sales that averaged out
in the mean but will give you very noisy
results also often our print sites have
a different production cost so if we're
working with comparing profits we need
to make sure we're holding that constant
it's better to have no match at all than
to have a distant match because you want
to have some sort of price with precise
results so then the second part of a
doing the experiment is looking at the
results and understanding what they are
so we kind of upgraded our plots in our
dashboard and built a d3 dashboard to
show how the experiments we're doing
this is a screenshot the dashboard has a
set of plots like this for each
algorithm
and this one's for the AR one so as I
said before the Sunday paper is a much
bigger deal than the weekday papers and
so we treated separately so Sunday's on
the right weekdays are on the left all
you can uncheck and check whatever
weekday boxes if you want to look at
subsets and the top plots show profit in
the treatment compared to the control
groups the bottom plots show how many
newspapers were delivering in the blue
with the darker color being our
treatment group and the lighter color
beam nature control group and then how
many newspapers actually sell with again
the treatment group in the darker color
and the control being a lighter color
and there are some you know statistics
and averages printed out of course I've
erased all the Y axes and all the
numbers so that you can't actually see
what happened so you know we saw these
sorts of results we saw I mean this
number I've erased is bigger than zero
so we are you know making profit
significantly compared to the original
algorithm so we were happy
however after talking with our
stakeholders about these results we
realized that they were not happy and
that is because of what you can see in
these bottom plots where the original
algorithm was really delivering way too
many newspapers to be optimal and you
can see that what our algorithm did was
cut way down on the number delivered and
so that saves a lot of money but we're
cutting into the sales a little bit but
significantly because in days where
they're a lot more sales than expected
originally there were loads of papers to
take up the slack but now they're there
sometimes we sell out more often and we
learned at this point that the sales
matter to the company more than just in
the sales profit but the circulation
numbers really also matter for
advertising purposes
while this is definitely true it's
really hard to quantify exactly how much
the circulation numbers matter for
advertising so um so we needed to modify
our algorithms to try to reduce this
loss in sales but given that we couldn't
really quantify like how many cents is
worth per paper to have this these sales
it's it was really difficult to put that
into our algorithm as it is so this was
a really good candidate for using a
constrained optimization so this is the
point where we need to go back with and
modify our algorithms so the constraint
optimization what we're constraining now
is really just the news vendor policy
function because we no longer really
want to optimize for profit we still
think that we have a good estimate of on
average how many papers will sell but
now the idea is to maximize not profit
but profit times this like Lagrangian
multiplier lambda parameter times sales
and lambda is negative because you want
sales to go up so if you instead of
optimizing for profit you find the
maximum of profit minus lambda times
sales then what you find is that for the
optimal draw you want the case where the
probability of the demand lesser equals
to the draw is greater than price minus
lambda minus cost over price minus
lambda and this is exactly the same as
the function for the equation before but
with these lambdas in here and so you
can see that what we're really doing is
we're effectively modifying the sales
price of the paper to go from price to
price minus lambda and land is negative
remember so that increases the sales
price effectively of the paper so it
makes it in this optimization it makes
it worth sending extra papers if we make
lambda more significant
so then this begs the question what
should we put as lambda and we left this
question to the stakeholders in the
circulation group who had been working
on this project for a long time so we've
basically made them this plot where the
y-axis is how much extra money we can
make them the x-axis is how much this
will cost them in sales and so you can
see as you make lambda a larger like
absolute value the profits go down but
we don't we start losing fewer fewer
sales down to the matching sales with
the original algorithm and actually this
line can keep going and this is actually
not zero profit like this is still
positive and so we said okay you know
here's the trade-off where should we put
lambda we kind of expected something
around here surprisingly they chose
something down here where they really
put a lot more weight on having as many
sales as possible at the expense of
maximizing the profit but still still
making a significantly higher profit
than we were before by using our
algorithm but in general it like we
found that this tunable knob approach is
really handy because we can run
experiments in different groups of
stores with different values of lambda
and come up with different alternatives
and you know costs and benefit of using
these lambdas and then leave the
ultimate decision to the stakeholders
and this really gives them the freedom
to be comfortable with our algorithms
and gives us the freedom of not having
to know absolutely everything about the
business decision decisions so this is a
quick plot about how we've been using
the experiments to compare the the
results on our dashboard these are each
different experiments are different
algorithms some of them are the Poisson
regression with different values of
and the green so this is Sunday this is
weekdays the green is the amount of
profit we've made over the BAU algorithm
the red is the difference in sales
compared to BAU algorithm you can see
that it's usually negative and basically
we show this to stakeholders were like
okay you know we think that these ones
are good and you probably won't like
these ones but what should we do and you
know for example they picked that one
[Music]
alright so that summarizes where we are
in terms of the the approach and the
algorithms that we have done I did also
want to go over the architecture of the
the APIs we haven't now recently the
times has been migrating a lot of its
data platforms to Google cloud and as
part of that we decided to be platform
this project onto Google cloud and it's
actually been great we took it as an
opportunity to make the process more
robust and have better data engineering
practices and we've been using mainly
app engine and App Engine flex we have
one one project for all of this but it
has three services a standard instance
for or you know multiple if necessary
for the front end and then two back-end
app engine flex instances one for the
reporting calculations and one for the
predictions really in order just to be
as modular as possible in the code and
then we use Google Cloud storage and
bigquery for storing a bunch of our data
and our configurations and then also you
know this is our internal ftp site where
we get and put all our input and output
data and we also use cloud sequel to
feed the the front-end web dashboard
this is all deployed via terrowin The
Times actually wrote its own truck in
drone jargon drone plugin for App Engine
and also for GE
I've been using that and so you know for
App Engine flex it goes via docker and
the Google Cloud repository but for a
standard it just goes straight there
since standard is its own docker image
basically um so I wanted to just go
through the same process that I went
through in one slide in the beginning
explaining how it's happening now on GCP
and basically the data transfer again is
still a weekly cron job it's on the
front end of the App Engine standard
instance we're using cached keys to
handle this because we don't know
exactly when the day is gonna show up
but we want to be checking for it as
early as possible so a task queue cat
task basically looks for the data and
then fails if it's not there and then
the cube retries it until basically it's
there or it's been a really long time in
which case it fails and we'll get emails
about it then logging for this whole
process is a stackdriver which can send
us emails upon some errors but also
quality checks and you know progress
status messages are sent to slack so it
is slack channel which is very zen it's
very boring which is pleasant and as
things go along it says things like I
can't really read it but you know
reporting finished see you know the
dashboard reporting validation checks
past you know prediction finished
whatever so that's nice to just keep an
eye on once the data transfer is
successfully done what that process does
is it puts everything in bigquery and so
the reporting process then is kicked off
risa data back and bigquery it
calculates all the aggregations and and
statistics about you know which
experiments are doing well you know how
how are the experiments going it
a lot of pandas which is why it's a
engine flex instance rather than a
standard instance say is the aggregated
data back to bigquery and then run some
tests on the data to make sure that
everything's okay like for example
making sure that the last weeks total
sales are within three sigma of previous
sales that we've seen is to make sure
that things look reasonable or the data
input we got seemed to be complete then
it sinks the VQ tables with cloud sequel
for the front end because the front end
has like for example a drop-down menu by
print site so you configure can filter
out all of the plots and everything by
specific print side if you're interested
in geographic differences but to have
that be responsive and fast enough time
we need to use cloud sequel rather than
bigquery which takes like some number of
seconds to do to do query so then once
the reporting quality checks are passed
the predictions start being run I mean
we retrain the model every week on the
new week of data and you know the
previous year also this processes is a
lot of scikit-learn a lot of Syfy uses
configuration input that we're keeping
in cloud storage saves the results back
to cloud storage and then again we run
some tests for unexpected changes and
the quantity of the the drawers that
were telling them to deliver and it
aborts again and sent us lots of
messages if it fails the tests finally
once the tests are passed it just the
front end just uploads the the
predictions to the FTP site where
they're handed off to the circulation
group so I mean that's really it I think
this project is a very interesting one
to work on because it has components of
a lot of different aspects that we see
in data science projects I think for
example we had to do some custom
algorithmic work to
you know to best optimize our sales for
given the domain knowledge specific for
this problem it was a cool opportunity
to do a bunch of engineering and reap
lat forming this in GCP which has
improved our process a lot it's been fun
to work on the experiments because the
the KPI here is pretty much money and
its really satisfying to work on this
and say look you know we actually made
this number of dollars compared to the
previous algorithm you know in the last
month because often with other projects
we just work on you know clicks you know
views and things like that that are less
concrete so this has been nice
and then finally about communication I
mean often you know data scientists
think we can like swoop into some
problem with our fancy machine learning
techniques and easily solve problems
better than they've ever been solved
before but in practice this is not
usually the way it works and it was
really surprising for us that or at
least for me that um that lay our first
algorithms where we were optimizing
strictly for profit they they didn't
actually outperform the original
algorithm by the standard so if
everybody who is involved in that and
yes our stakeholders so in doing this
we've learned a lot about the business
and it's been nice to to have this
communication and be able to integrate
the stakeholders like quantitative and
qualitative concerns into our
quantitative algorithms and so make it a
successful project for for everyone
Thanks
[Applause]
we have time for a few questions it'll
be in office hours following lunch
so you can find her down the hall there
questions just quick building on the
presentation that was before you it's
interesting for you even thinking about
this marrying any sort of predictive
capabilities as to the headlines the
stories or something like that to the
demand forecast
well dealing with print distribution
kind of makes it harder to to do very
granular experiments like that just
because the feedback is so broad and
it's just like somebody bought the paper
there is you know headline testing and
at the times but it's on it it's a much
different process because the the print
side of things it's it's not just the
fact that we don't know what articles
people are actually reading in the
newspaper but it's also that the data is
so delayed that it's it makes it harder
to do granular level experiments like
that I meant more like around elections
you know the week before an election
that kind of demand will pick up or if
there's this particular story that's
getting a lot of Attraction that you
know it's gonna run for two weeks yeah
so there are some things like that that
are really hard to predict you know for
major news events in a machine-learning
way what the you know final reality of
this is gonna be and actually for those
cases the print stakeholders just
manually use their brains and and say
how many newspapers to send so they
override us if they know that there's
gonna be a big news story tomorrow also
I mean we have to say these predictions
it will fall like week in advance so
it's before the news happens so unless
it's an election or something but but
they often midweek they you know they
call everybody up and they're like okay
you know tomorrow's gonna be a biggie
and double the number that were gonna
send so that's something that
we've thought about how we could be
integrated better into that process but
it's hard given the manual nature of the
process thank you any other questions
hey um so you talked about how demand
was like a linear a latent variable and
as linear function withdraw so that like
if you sellout then you assume that the
demand was higher than the the number of
draws you sent but what about like local
of like psychological effects have only
seen like one copy left or something
yeah so basically we we've played around
with trying to see if we can measure
effects that that violate this
reasonable assumption a reasonable
assumption of you know if there's a
paper and somebody wants it somebody's
gonna buy it I don't think we saw any
evidence for it
[Music]